when Amna mahmoud's one-year-old
daughter Hawa started to lose weight
four months ago she thought it was just
a phase but how was Health continued to
deteriorate and now Amna has brought her
to a malnutrition Center for treatment
because of the cost of food in the
market most of the time we can only
afford to give her milk things are very
expensive and even when I nurse her
there's not enough to keep her full
hundreds of children in Casella here in
eastern Sudan suffer from malnutrition
it's the result of a poor harvest the
previous season that caused food prices
to rise and left many families
struggling to provide for their children
recent floods have also destroyed
hundreds of thousands of hectares of
crops raising concerns about food
security especially in rural areas
the UN says 3 million children around
the country are suffering from
malnutrition some cases are so severe at
stunting their growth with some children
hardly gaining any height as they age
eight-year-old son Mahmoud is one such
case
when he's four years old
sometimes he went to bed without dinner
now all his cousins the kids in the
neighborhood were born around the same
time have grown but he's still the same
height
have a million of the children suffering
malnutrition are categorized as severe
cases and in urgent need of Aid
according to the children's agency
UNICEF so I told them
while nutrition is responsible for the
death of 50 of children under five so
there is an urgent need for the
different sectors to come together to
address the root causes we have already
started a cash transfer program for
mothers and they're starting to come to
transfers for prenatal and postnatal
checkups but we need to expand that to
include as many mothers as we can
Amna hopes her daughter regains her
health soon but fears that as long as
she struggles with the ability to afford
food her condition will get worse Heber
Morgan Al Jazeera aroma kasala